Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
Continuing and where we left off.
yesterday and for the past few days with
respect to the times, occasions and
instances in which it is preferred that
a person have woo, that a person make
woo.
We've mentioned thus far three
instances.
Number one, the remembrance of Allahik
in general any.
Number two,
the second
sleep.
Person sleeps any sleep
doesn't matter if it's a long sleep, day
sleep, night sleep.
Number three
Quran. No, this is what
that is. That is what wudoo is
obligatory for.
We are talking about what is preferred
for a person to have wudoo.
So in the let's make a distinction here.
What do in order for me to do I have to
have to do it. It is haram for me to do
it without wudoo. Three things
handling the mus
right
around thea and salah. I have to have
wudoo for these three things. This is
agreed upon amongst the former.
Okay.
Now we moved on to what it is preferred
for me to have wudoo for. I don't have
to have wudoo to do it. I don't have to
but it is best. It is the sunnah for me
to have wudoo when I do it. Number one
remembrance of Allah any right. Number
two is sleep. Any sleep. Number three is
what we discussed yesterday which is
al janaba right. If a person who is in a
state of janaba sexual impurity
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam would
make wubul to do one of four things.
Okay. So imagine with me the instance
here.
He would be in a state of janeneba
sexual. It's sexual impurity. We all
know what jeneba is. And he would make
wudoo, not he would just make wudoo like
he would for salah to do one of four
things or more.
Number one to eat something.
Number two to drink something. Number
three to sleep. Number four to have
relations a second time or a third or a
10th time or 20th time. It's not meant
that first or second meaning between
encounters if you will. And so
what is meant here is that a person in a
state of janaba, if he wants to eat
something, if he wants to drink
something, if he wants to sleep, if he
wants to have relations again, it is the
sunnah to make woo, right? What kind of
wudoo? Full wuboo as you would for
salah. Okay?
And we will come to read that what is
even better than that is to make between
encounters
as the prophet sallall.aii wasallam
would also
do
is that if he had relations with one of
his wives he would make before having
relations a second time. Not always, not
every single time but often. And this is
the best of the best of and the most
complete of actions. Okay. What is
another thing that a person should have
to do or a person is encouraged to have
for
[Silence]
you.
Oh.
[Silence]
And so the author says
a fourth instance when it is preferred
that a person make wudoo is
before they make
bathe. You know before they bathe
means to
bathe.
It is
that when a person begins bathing they
begin with woo.
So let's describe what is if we were and
we're going to have a whole chapter on
and its rulings but it's okay for us to
mention it now. Actually we've already
had a ch we've already done haven't we?
Yeah I think we have. It's okay. It
warrants repeating. So,
what is gusset?
Here is a nice fun, not fun, but here is
a nice fact
that will help you understand the Arabic
language just a little bit more.
Every single word in Arabic
that starts with the letter,
that's with a dot on top.
Right?
Every single word in the Arabic language
that starts with the letter
articulates
covering something in its entirety.
everyone,
every letter, every word that starts
with
means or has something to do with
covering
something,
right? So for instance,
Elashia is one of the names of the day
of judgment, right? It's referred to as
Alia because it will encompass all of
creation. Nobody will be missing on that
day. Or for instance, alim alim is big
giant clouds that cover the sky is
referred to as or for instance if a
person drowns what do we call it?
because they've been submerged and
covered in in water or for instance
sleep, right? Right. It's referred to
as
right
is spiritual
spiritual
sleep, spiritual slumber is referred
to as because it covers the person's
mind entirely. They can't even tell that
they're asleep. Right? And that is
the word
which means to bathe. So from a
linguistic standpoint, what is the bare
minimum of
covering the entire body with water with
the intention of removing major sexual
impurity that's
if a person does that they have
performed
it is when a person encompasses their
entire body
right
including the nose and mouth.
When they encompass that with water
and they have the intention of this is
what is that's the bare minimum.
That is the bare minimum.
Okay. But what is the sunnah of how did
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
bathe? Well, whenever he would bathe, he
would bathe as narrates Muslim. She
narrates his. This is how he would make.
He would begin with washing his hands.
Then he would wash his front and back
private parts. And then he would make
wudoo as he would for salah full wudoo.
Sometimes he would wash his feet.
Sometimes he would leave his feet till
after
but he would make woo just you
would for salah
and then he would pour the water on his
head three times and work work because
his hair remember his hair was long. It
was always long. His hair was always
long.
He would work the water into his scalp.
So, and remember, he didn't have a
shower head. Fancy stuff us, fancy
pants stuff. We have the fancy stuff. He
sallaiam
had it in a container. So, he would take
it with his hands and pour the water on
his head three times, right? three times
on his head to make sure that he could
and then he would wash the right side of
his body
and then he would wash the left side of
his body and then he would move places
and wash his feet. Why move places?
Well, there wasn't a drain or he's
makingul on the ground. So, he would
move places.
For us, this would translate to just
staying where we are in in the shower.
And he would wash his feet, right foot
and then left foot. That's
so it's the sunnah that when we make we
always begin with what
in the way that I just described.
foreign.
[Silence]
Thanks for fixing that.